hello everyone thank you for joining us
back again this next section will be the
cross questioning section the way this
will work is those speakers will be at
the podium we will begin with Mohammed
hijab
he will ask a question he'll have one
minute to formulate the question Edward
you'll have two minutes to answer this
will continue until Mohammed has been
able to ask three questions then we will
alternate that means Edward will ask
three questions again each question will
be one minute each and each answer this
time by Mohammed will be two minutes
each so if I can ask both Edward and
Mohammed to join me at the podium our go
to the podium thank you if you like it
the wet into the just one mic okay oh
okay all right
thank Frank Sinatra and Egan Martin from
1950 I'm the one old enough to know that
joke okay yeah okay I was gonna say that
you touched upon morality and I think
it's an important thing to talk about
because I have lots of intrigue to hear
your answer to the particularly this
particular question on naturalism what
scientific explanation can you provide
for the existence or the objectivity of
morality the answer is that I can give a
better explanation for morality on
atheism than on theism even if it's not
a perfect answer because on theism
someone looks into a book and without
any proof that God really said it's
saying well God said it therefore it
must be true regardless of what we think
about it just because God said it which
eclipses human reason on atheism what we
do is we wrestle it out with our
reasoning and there are a whole avenue
of areas by which we can assess morality
and even if they're not perfect they're
more reliable than believing in a deity
for instance there's consequentialism
the consequences of actions being good
or bad there is the notion that our
moral values stem from our biological
nature see the problem with saying that
morality comes from God is circular
because what you're doing is you are
positing a God so you can have objective
moral values that you can then use to
try to show that that God exists and
that's is not a valid form of argument
which is
a theistic naturalism what scientific
experiment would you conduct the sample
or could you refer to that tells us
about the existence of mathematics how
can you prove mathematics through
science is very easily proved
mathematics empirically for instance two
of one object and two of another object
equals four but what's important about
that is that is so axiomatic that it
couldn't be altered for instance God
couldn't appear right now and say by
divine Fiat there are three debaters
standing at the podium not two and so
mathematics and logic are actually
arguments against the supernatural
because they show laws of logic and laws
of mathematics that cannot be altered
you see conceptually it doesn't even
work to say God could make 2m 2 equals 5
and so on naturalism we discover the
laws of nature we don't invent them and
they're not prescribed by anybody so for
instance we discovered the laws of
geometry nobody invented them we
discovered the workings of calculus we
discovered the laws of engineering
nobody invented it that if we put up a
building this way it'll collapse if we
put up a building the other way it will
collapse we discovered it just like we
discover what medicines work so
therefore on naturalism we would expect
that these laws could not be altered by
anyone a god or any other type of being
the mind all those things are
first-person but on this point once
again
have another question because you made
mention of some historical events now
obviously we both believe in parts of
history for example we believe in you
know the slave trade you believe in the
Holocaust we believe in you know things
that have happened even all the way back
to the prehistoric age if witness
testimony which is what is required for
history to take place for example your
mother's history of what happened to her
or whatever it may be how can you how
can you legitimize witness testimony or
naturalism and if it's not legitimized
does that mean that we can deny things
like slavery the Holocaust and so on
well you see the answer to that is by
empirical evidence we know that certain
things can happen if I said that I flew
here on an airplane today nobody would
question it if I said I just flap my
arms and flew here bodily you would
question it if I told you that somebody
crossed a river to get to the other side
you would accept it if I told you that
somebody was levitated from one side of
the river to the other you wouldn't this
shows that we have an inbuilt already
recognition through logic and reason and
experience of understanding eyewitness
events that are within the realm of what
we know to be probable and those which
are not if I said that somebody drove me
here tonight for the debate in a car you
would believe me if I said space aliens
picked me up in an interstellar
spacecraft and brought me here you
wouldn't believe me so we shouldn't shy
away from the common sense experience
that already helps us distinguish the
natural from the supernatural okay
Mohammed I'm handing you of five
different translations of surah 434 each
one talks about men being in charge of
women and there's nothing corresponding
about women being in charge
men in each of the seven translations
from different respected translators of
the Koran speak about husband's having
the right to under circumstances of
defiance and arrogance beat their wives
do you agree or disagree with both men
ruling over women in the surah and the
permission to beat them as set forth in
the surah I certainly disagree with the
translation because the wealth of our
moon in Arabic means maintain us and
protect us and this word hi Maya Puma
literally means the stand up and that's
why you'll find that the majority of
translators translate like that as for
the verse that talks about da Dada which
is the Arabic word almost there is a
consensus among the scholars of Islam
that this is not to be in vengeful or
attacking or harmful or hurtful action
this is talking about something which is
symbolic and the evidence of that is
hilarious
let me said that you cannot harm or
reciprocate humph so I think there is a
problem here with the understanding of
the first and also the purposes let
Audrey poem Allah don't hit the women
slaves of Allah meaning women and he
says the worst of you are those who hear
the women and that's why I think if you
look at the totality of evidence then
there is a bit more nuance than you
think Muhammad you quoted the Quran a
lot tonight let me ask you why is the
Quran a more credible final revelation
of God having been dictated to the
Prophet by the angel Gabriel then the
Book of Mormon as the final revelation
of God having been dictated in the 19th
century in upstate New York by the angel
Moroni to the Prophet Joseph Smith the
reason why is because the Quran has
certain parameters and certain
challenges that the Book of Mormon
doesn't have for example as the
inevitability challenge it has to
raishin challenge the quran is the only
preserved book as predictions that
predict the future that couldn't have
been no another time on probability we
find it very difficult I explained that
in the conclusion I'll give you one give
you more expansion of what I'm saying
the Quran has a language that completely
discos or discs of the Arabic language
of the people of the time and it was
recognized by those linguists as
something which was extraordinary the
Quran has a structural feature that even
orientalist scholars like raymond Ferran
have looked at and said that this is
something which cannot be possible
considering the circumstantial
revelation of the Quran so those many
reasons and I think the main point is
the Quran gives us a falsification
challenge and since you're a fan of
science the fact that it gives us a
falsification challenge makes it in many
ways quite scientific Muhammad you have
many times embraced what we would call
the Kalam cosmological argument the
first cause argument if in fact time and
space began with the Big Bang and if
something cannot come from nothing but
God created Allah created the world ex
nihilo out of nothing
how did an immaterial being with no
physical attributes no physical brain or
body create everything around us in a
context where there was no time and
space for a to cause B how did he do it
how did what was the mechanism by which
this immaterial being without time and
space created time and space and matter
well as Arab say other than delete laces
allow other so it's argument from
ignorance if we don't know how something
works it doesn't mean it is false
however having said that there is no
agreement among Muslims that the
universe was created X Nylund so there
are some people like Al has early and
others who did believe this what other
people I couldn't take me I believe that
God perpetually created different things
pretty eternally so once again there is
a scope of interpretation in the Islamic
texts either way the point is causation
doesn't even factor
because cause of course something which
brings rise the phenomenon whereas
dependency is something which is relying
on something else
so time or no time whether you believe
in the a theory of time or the B theory
of time you still have to reckon you
have to deal with the fact that you have
things which rely upon each other and if
we compile all the things which rely
upon each other together you would have
no existence so you have to have an
independent so the contingency argument
does not rely upon causality which is
why to be frank with you I didn't make
thank you so much that concludes the
cross rapid-fire question portion of the
debate the last portion of the debate
will be the audience Q&A I'll quickly
give an overview of how this is supposed
to work I have three questions here from
Mohammed the question is here for Edward
one for both of you I will ask the
question whoever it is directed towards
will have two minutes to respond and
then two minutes will be given to the
other person to also respond presenting
their own perspectives so with that I
will begin with the first question okay
before I do that I have a request if
people can actually not use the Wi-Fi
and I think we have too many people and
it's crashing the livestream so if you
guys have data Verizon is great
right okay all right so we'll begin the
first question is directed towards
Mohammed why would God not show himself
when he knows the controversy that goes
through everyone's mind well it's a good
question thank you very much the
question has an empiricist
presupposition which is that in fact
knowledge should be known through the
five senses well as we've discovered
today that's not actually the case so
things like the logic or the the logic
through which science is done is
actually based on metaphysical logical
principles time is not seen mathematics
is not based on science there are lots
of things which are felt which are which
are found out without the empirical
method so the this empirical
naturalistic presupposition is rejected
and if we look at the development of
philosophy in the 20th century we'll
find that even people like AJ Mayer who
wrote a book on positivism he admits to
some of these things and he capitulates
intellectually to these points so
frankly what I'll say to you is that the
question is flawed is based on an
empiricist presupposition which would
mean by extension that science itself
couldn't exist because it's based on
presuppositions which are unscientific
otherwise on thank you the issue is
there are things like logic and
mathematics where the very working out
of the theorems show you the
truthfulness or falsity
however the question of whether God
exists or not is a factual question and
thus makes it subject to an empirical
investigation whether there is such an
all powerful being in the universe is a
factual question akin to whether space
aliens have visited us whether in fact
we do live after death or not when it
comes to questions of fact the empirical
method does apply but there's another
problem here in that both the Bible and
the Quran unmistakably promise eternal
punishment for non belief as a matter of
fundamental fairness we can say that it
is unfair of God to punish us for not
believing in he
if he withholds evidence that would
enable us to believe in him and that's
the argument from divine hiddenness so
the laws of logic and mathematics don't
have causative properties so you can't
say the number seven as an abstraction
causes something to happen but you can
say and they do say as Muhammad does God
does cause things to happen and if an
agent has causative powers and can make
or break something that subject to
empirical investigation
thank you both a second question this is
directed towards you Edward why are a
pious --tz-- focused on a god that would
service any God would not function to
offer us what we want what so the
question is basically if a God exists
why are why are a theist so focused on
the fact that a god like that would
serve us because God Himself is
transcendent and he would not
necessarily function to offer us what we
want okay the question though has a
problem and that's that if you accept an
abstract deity that has not claimed to
have been revealed to humanity then it's
understandable that God would not tailor
the evidence to meet our needs but if a
God has supposedly given us a number of
revelations Bible Quran Book of Mormon
whatever else then we have a right to
use our reason to expect that such a God
is intending to reveal itself to us and
the failure of that God to fill in the
gaps of the revelation or the failure of
that God to provide us with a reliable
revelation makes non-belief reasonable
if non belief is reasonable its in
culpable and we are not blameworthy for
non belief because we weren't given
sufficient evidence if we are not
blameworthy for non belief then it's
unfair to punish us for not believing
what we didn't have sufficient evidence
to believe and if we are punished
for not believing what we didn't have
sufficient evidence to believe then that
calls God's moral perfection into
question because we are being punished
unjustly no - okay I think the reason
why he's using this argument is
potentially because he had conversations
with Christians before but the theology
is a little bit different but the
premise is true Edward Assange is
absolutely correct in fact if God
doesn't reveal himself to you and then
punishes you as a result this is unjust
and that's why the Quran says while my
own my Divina had Tanabata rasoolallah
chapter 17 verse 15 that we were not
gonna punish them until we sent him a
messenger so scholars of Islam said even
if you die an atheist or a Hindu or a
Christian and even though you're born
with this fitrah with this
predisposition which wasn't tackled
hopefully you'll talk about it this
predisposition to believe in God which
we have evidence for now even though all
of that is in place God will still not
punish those individuals until they're
given sufficient exposure and that is
exactly correct I think you're right
thank you
the next question is directed towards
Muhammad so it's basically the case of
bad design in science there is a concept
of the steel features futures that are a
hindrance or otherwise less than perfect
and many organisms if the universe runs
without inconsistency what would explain
the studio futures and the particular
examples that was given is the woman's
pelvis which is far too small and
creates a very difficult and painful
birthing process well I think this is
called the argument of ignorance just
because you don't know the function of
something it doesn't mean this
functionless so for example we don't
know what the appendix does it doesn't
mean it has no function it just means we
haven't discovered that yet we don't
know why two electrons can be in one
place at the same time on quantum
mechanics it doesn't mean that's a false
notion even though it goes against the
rules of logic and it goes against some
of the things conventions that we
believe in so just because you don't
know something it doesn't make it false
so that's the first point
for the second point of bad design I
mean who's the judge of bad design I
mean at least with the fine-tuning
argument you have some kind of
probability mathematical probability
that can be attached to this kind of
equation you're saying that the chances
of there not being you know a universe
or the universe having a non-life
permitting rate range is X which is a
mathematical kind of rendering so here
we have to be kind of honest here and
say that this is an aesthetic value
judgment at best
and aesthetic value judgements are not
our opinions frankly your opinion if you
see something that's bad design that's
your opinion you might think it's bad
design but there might be a reason now
there's one more thing I wanna ask cuz
I've got a minute left I think people
have misunderstood my on this my
argument from uniformity I'll add it to
the conclusion like my good friend for
us the Hobby mentioned one time in the
podcast I had done with him for example
let's take a coin if we flip a coin it
can either be heads or tails today we
can flip it it's either gonna be heads
or tails tomorrow is going to be either
heads or tails we don't expect the coin
to be flipped and turned into a
butterfly why because we accept that
there's a kind of coherence that exists
throughout kind of constants that exist
so in order to do science you need to
know or you need to presuppose that this
uniformity exists otherwise your
calculations today will be meaningless
tomorrow and that's why Albert Einstein
said that a priori we expect a chaotic
universe meaning from the mind you
expect there not to be this kind of
order so this underpins or is even more
undercutting if you like than the
fine-tuning argument which is why I
presented it so that's that's it thank
you the problem is that when you posit a
god who is supposed to be all-powerful
and morally perfect then defects in our
design are not justified based on those
attributes of God for instance I pointed
out how the gene that can help fight
malaria can also cause sickle cell
anemia we know that we humans have back
problems because we stood up too soon we
know that there are defects in our
bodies we could be more resistant to
cancer we could be more resistant to
viruses
we could have a better digestive system
so God cannot get off the hook here
because he is presented as an
all-powerful being who is morally
perfect an all-powerful being who is
morally perfect doesn't make these
missteps in design and we already know
our vulnerability to disease for
instance we already know that we just
have a very few decades to be in good
condition and then as we get older we
begin to decline and so that's not
something that we would expect from a
morally perfect God we wouldn't expect
unnecessary pain if God wants us to take
our hand off the fire so we don't get
burned we would expect pain but if we're
trapped in a burning forest and we
burned to death painfully pain has no
value and we wouldn't expect that
unnecessary suffering with no purpose on
theism it's more likely on atheism so
given the claims of God's moral
perfection and omnipotence a defects in
design are not defensible we say this is
the difference between me and a
religious person I'm subject to evidence
religions don't change regardless of the
evidence but an empirically minded
atheists like me would if right now
Mohamed and I were levitated to the
ceiling if my father who was dead for 18
years walked in this room right now in
his inimitable Yiddish accent and I
recognized him asking me why I'm not in
my office working and then floated in
the air and and and and said both of you
Mormonism is the true religion if
Mohammed and I right now were teleported
to Mecca and I saw the most amazing
astronomical displays
telling me to become a Muslim right away
I would now you might say well this is
the result of an advanced space alien
but being an evidential assassin a
chiral being until someone showed me
that it was advanced space aliens so the
difference between atheists like me and
those who subscribe to religion is we
are open to changing if we have direct
evidence whereas there very few
religious people who would say if this
happened I would not believe in God
whereas atheists like me can clearly say
if the following things happen I will
believe in God but we all know they
won't happen but if they did I would can
I answer yes away you get two minutes we
yeah the first point are not being
religious is the pipe that depends on
how you define religion because frankly
if you take a like an Emile Durkheim
approaches or sociologists he defined
religion and more broad terms than would
be found in vernacular vernacular lien
dictionaries for example which has to be
through God or ever frankly you could
make the argument that if these people
are very religious in so much as they
have axioms and they have leaps of faith
which they believe in for instance if we
take for example science science and
especially something like quantum
physics you don't do the experiments
yourself you rely upon witness testimony
you don't go into laboratory and repeat
experiments X amount of times in order
to believe it so in order for you to
have an understanding of science you
have to have a leap of faith in trusting
those individuals who teach you about
science your teachers your schoolbooks
and so on I mean you believe in equality
and once again these are precepts which
frankly are axiomatic meaning they don't
have any evidence to substantiate them
even John Locke who is the founder of
liberalism he based it on God by the way
and that's why in your deeper
Declaration of Independence created
beings as being referred to over and
over again so really you don't have a
right up estimate right school to talk
about equality without having some kind
of leap of faith frankly in those things
so atheists have faith all the time they
have faith in things they don't see they
have faith in things they don't interact
with and what I'm gonna say is that this
is where as John Gray said
some people can rap a you know
discussion of ideology in sociological
format and make it seem as if it's a
religious but in fact it is actually in
terms of its conventions and epistemic
way the same as any kind of religious
belief as for levitating and so on well
you believe in a levitating but it just
has to happen in the quantum physics
realm where things do levitate and
things do flow Harry Potter exists in
the quantum physics world but an atheist
would never believe it unless a
scientist told them that's believe
that's what God does what God provide us
was autonomy our free world and does
that negate the good and evil argument
yes so on Islamic traditionalism God has
endowed us with what you call Hell or
the idea of choice of free will
and in fact even is a necessary part of
that because if you don't have evil you
cannot make a decision there will just
be good and good to decide from you
can't decide from good and good they
have to be good and bad and therefore
you must be tested if a test makes no
sense with the existence with the
non-existence of evil a test makes no
sense with the non-existence of evil so
sometimes the bad thing can be good for
you well assets a crochet a whole Hyrule
on the Quran says you could hate
something but it's actually very good
for you and the thing is on theism on a
silently ISM we believe in another
domain it's a metaphysical domain which
is young p.m. the day of judgment
whereby all of those things that we are
wronged in in the dunya the worldly life
you'll be recompensed for that so we
don't believe that when a child dies
that's just a random rearrangement of
atoms as would be the case by the way or
naturalism so random rearrangement of
atoms if I slap a snowman and unlock his
head off is the same is if I cut a kid's
head off because it's just on naturalism
frankly it's just you know a
rearrangement of atoms and in order for
you to make any sense of that you'd have
to impose a subjective value judgment on
it which you have to
faith in order to have in the first
place so frankly I mean what we believe
is that the injustice is of this world
Hitler for example was a very unjust man
kill six million individuals he will be
punished hopefully perpetually in a
domain where in which the punishment is
not limited justice cannot be done on
naturalism it can only be done on a kind
of system a metaphysical system which
the undoes all of the wrongs that
happened in this world we may not like
the implications of a godless world but
that doesn't mean that a God will come
into existence just to rescue us from
those implications we may not like the
fact that we end at death but that
doesn't mean a god will come about just
so that we don't end a death of that God
doesn't otherwise exist the concept of
free will is given more credit than it
deserves if you have two children
you don't let one of your children push
the other off a cliff just so as not to
interfere in free will and so the
question of free will or even the
benefits of it do not justify the
extreme pain and the extreme suffering
that we undergo so for instance if we
need to feel pain when we put our hand
on a hot stove that's understandable but
that pain does not serve a useful
purpose if we are being innocently burnt
by evil people and we have to suffer
that agonizing death so the fact that
there is gratuitous unnecessary
unexplained horrendous suffering goes
way beyond necessary slight evils and
suffering which would have a beneficial
and corrective purpose so we can't say
that any amount of suffering or any
amount of horrible experience is
justified because we need that in which
two distinct
which the good even a small amount of
evil or a bearable amount of evil is
enough to distinguish the good it is the
presence of unexplained gratuitous
horrendous suffering that is
incompatible with an all good and
all-powerful God thank you
last question directed towards Edward to
summarize essentially if that provides
objective morality do you believe there
is such a thing as objective morality
and if so how would you explain why a
theists 30 years ago would object to say
homosexuality well I believe that there
are objective moral values and they're
not prescribed by anybody there is no
lawgiver now I was just asked thirty
years ago how a theists would have
responded to homosexuality this actually
proves my point thirty years ago many
atheists may not have recognized the
importance of allowing such personal
freedom what that means is not that
anybody who condemned persons who loved
those of the same gender were right or
wrong then it meant that we hadn't yet
discovered the truth that these are
people that deserve equal rights so for
instance in the 1950s when I was growing
up people would be arrested for being
gay they would be put in prison for
being gay the fact that we don't do that
now and it's been illegal to do so in
any state since 2003 shows that the more
we evolve the more we discover these
moral truths not that somebody invents
them and imposes us on them that by our
natural development we discover these
truths for instance it used to be that
religious people would burn women
accused of being witches but we don't do
that anymore
because we discovered the moral truth
that it's wrong to do that to these
women irrespective of the Bible saying
thou shalt not suffer a witch
live so the more we get away from
religious fundamentalist edicts the more
moral and tolerant we become which shows
that morality cannot be dependent on
religious fundamentalist or Orthodox
edicts because it is our pulling away
from them that makes us more moral more
compassionate and more tolerant I don't
know what religious edicts the American
Founding Fathers had used in order to
for at least some period of time allow
slavery Grace's slavery and what Stalin
used in order to do what he did what
Hitler used frankly to do what he did
this is not the work of religion this is
the work of people who use ideological
justification in order to commit certain
acts the same way is which something is
conceivable to think that some religious
people will use religious justification
in orders commit certain acts so I don't
think there should be an epistemic
preferencing of one one thing over
another here I think you should just
realize that epistemology drives us to
certain forces certain things and you
can't really say what religion is better
than on religion once again that would
depend on how you define religion in the
first place but having said all of that
I mean we've talked a lot about gay
rights today and all those things but on
the harm principle which is what John
Stuart Mill proposed part of social
social liberalism that you can do
whatever you want so long as you don't
harm anyone else well frankly that would
entail that sex between a brother and
sister or brother and a brother so long
as this contraception use and there's no
deformed babies that should be allowed
as well and I haven't seen anyone doing
incest right activism in America for a
very long time and frankly on liberalism
that's what you should do you know just
because they're a minority group of
people that are still in the closet in
the incest closet it doesn't mean now
that they should be treated any less on
liberalism so I think we have to be we
have to be completely honest with
ourselves in our social analysis and if
what we're doing is selecting certain
social things which have become popular
early 21st century to make a case about
God's existence and I think really would
be
academically disingenuous so I think at
the end of the day whatever principle
you're going to have you have to apply
it across the board and if it is the
home principle and social liberalism
then incest should be allowed in this
country and people should be able to do
that
thank you final question this is
directed to both of you Edward because
you began I'll start with Mohammed
please address the viability of Pascal's
wager well I mean Pascal is kind of like
it's not really an argument to be honest
with you which is why them kind of make
ace Pascal was a famous mathematician
who talked about you know basically
making a wager you know betting on the
fact that God exists because the because
doing otherwise may mean that you know
you'll die and go to hell and so on and
so therefore what makes sense to do that
what we're saying is that fair enough
there is some truth in that I mean if
you think about the Quran actually
affirms some of that where it says you
know full in care Amina angel appear in
the LA he sumukha fortune be what if it
was from God what if this was from God
and you are disbelieving in it so it's a
full experiment right it's more of a
thought experiment rather than an
arguments I think the maximum we can do
with it is you have a thought experiment
make people think about death you know
make people think about the fact that
they're going to die and what kind of
ideology or what kind of belief system
they want to have would them one day in
their graves frankly because atheism
will not do anything as a matter of fact
now I'm not saying therefore God exists
because that's not an argument I've made
that clear it's not an argument to say
well the implications of atheism is that
you know you're going to be in the sick
bed you're gonna be maybe 75 years old 1
and 2 people in United States of America
are gonna have cancer just like in the
UK put into cancer research and what is
better for you I mean as it should be
optimistic that there's going to be
continuation of that life or to know
that actually you're going to just
become bones and dust obviously from an
implications perspective theism and
especially theism with afterlife
implications has better employed
optimistic implications for you your
memories will be wiped away your
experiences will be wiped away and your
bodies will be wiped away
that's atheist naturalism but the
implications of of theism is that
actually there we continuation that's
just the beginning and so this is not an
argument why is an implication
well there is a problem with Pascal's
wager now Mohammed just admitted that
the Quran does talk about punishment and
hell for not believing in Islam as the
Bible talks about punishment and Hell
for not believing in Christianity what
Pascual wager did was it made the error
of automatically assuming that if there
is a God this being will judge us by how
we worship this being rather than how
good we are to each other
and so the wager actually is false
because it presupposes without proof
that God is such an evil being if there
is a God that regardless of how good we
are unless we adopt the right religion
we will burn in hell forever now I'm
sure that Pascal who was a Christian
would not have accepted that someone is
meeting the wager if they were Muslim
and I think that the defect is whenever
we say without any evidence whatsoever
other than ancient hearsay in ancient
books which we know were written by
fallible men as women weren't even
involved in the writing of these books
when we say we are certain that the
ultimate force in the universe
will punish you unless you adopt my
religion that is nothing but primitive
exclusivism I think we got one more
thank you vote that concludes our
audience Q&A we will now proceed to the
closing statements each person will have
15 minutes to give theirs and we will
begin with Mohammad we're ready to go
get your notes
fifteen
that's done
all right please come down 15 minutes
left let me finish
I'll start witness quiet I saw inspired
just so quickly I'm sorry now just to
quickly kind of comment on the last
thing that he talked about ancient
hearsay and so on democracy is an
ancient concept liberalism is an ancient
concept it's still it's still adopted by
you know mainstream society that's the
genetic fallacy basically to criticize
something based on where it came from
anyway I found quite interesting in the
last speech that Eddie
ed would have he actually made an
interesting capitulation he admitted
that 99% of things natural science can
explain that means 1% of things are
supernatural that means miracles are
possible so that is very happy Villa all
right
secondly now what do you talked about
about cause and effect now the
definition of a cause is something which
brings rise to phenomena I can cause a
house to be for example I can build a
house yes I can build a house but I can
die and the house will continue to be
yes so I don't need to exist in order
for the house to continue existing
dependence on the other hand is when you
rely on something else so he made the
mistake of saying that contingency which
is dependence relies upon cause and
effect it doesn't which is why I didn't
really mention cause and effect to avoid
this discussion altogether let us agree
for the same imbalance
okay let's agree that there's no such
thing as causing effects the contingency
argument the way I framed there is still
valid because I didn't mention cause and
effect at all let me tell you why first
interesting atheists when he was
promising because a logical argument the
Hazaras argument that we
Lane Craig and those other guys are
making popula now in this country it's a
house that is argument everything that
begins to exist has a course the
universe began to exist therefore the
universe has a cause
okay so Bertrand Russell said but this
is the problem of composition because
you're saying that just because there
are causes in the universe it doesn't
mean that that cause will be applied to
the universe so he says for example just
because we have mothers as part of the
human race it doesn't mean that the
human race itself has mother imagine a
more like Trump like wolf yeah just
because this is Bertrand Russell is a
very valid argument he says just because
the world is made up of small parts it
doesn't mean that the wall itself is
small he's right Bertrand Russell was
right however what if the world is made
up of red paths the morning stuff can be
red so the fallacy of composition is a
double-edged sword because in order for
it to be a proper fallacy it needs to
have perfect knowledge of the whole if
you don't have perfect knowledge of the
whole you can't claim it to be a fallacy
so both the theists and the atheists are
in a good lock because they see is to
say well it can't be the small part
can't be the me but the fiercest aim or
the red part can make red bricks can
make a red wall and both can be possible
but both both can be argued against you
see so this is why I use the contingency
argument let me bring back the argument
that I use causation for the sake of
argument no problem you can have
causation let's pretend you know there's
no let's pretend it's possible that it
can exist and it's possible they can't
ask for the universe on a logical basis
however contingency dependents
I made in ontological arguments a
mathematical argument yes now you can't
have the existence of things if
everything else
if existence depends upon dependent
things existence would never exist you
have two independent outside and what is
it necessary independent however as
different yes and we said a possible
existence is something which can be
rearranged
I'm not going to be really am late Craig
here today I know you're used to this I
you season is debated William Lane Craig
this is his argument I know the
weaknesses of the argument I didn't use
this argument I want the most
undercutting argument no one can crack
this argument I've read from Plato to
live lives all the way through to
Russell and believe me this is the
argument no one can solve this is the
uncrackable code so he tried to crack
the code by saying well the necessary
existence should be what I'm saying
their complete opposite I'm saying that
it's impossible for it to be made up of
parts and still be the necessary
existence because a possible existence
is an existence that is subject to
change so to use this phraseology if we
look at the weight of the evidence the
totality of the evidence where
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence we have an
extrude we have an absolutely
extraordinary evidence which works in
the mind mathematically and works in
physical reality cosmologically and
works on first principles and we get the
independent self-sufficient
one entity which we as Muslims call
Allah that's it
well it was the multiverse what if
there's a multiverse no problem have a
multiple an infinite amount of universes
or more even just universes because why
discriminate towards universes creations
it still depend upon those things and we
said it can't be that because you can
envisage taking a universe in and out
and so it's dependent upon the structure
it's over you stay here
it's important to be honest with
ourselves he's a lawyer a lot of lawyers
I referred to as Liars but he's not one
of them he's a good man and as a lawyer
when he goes into the the courtroom he
refers to witness testimony he makes
abductive arguments like CSI CSI
forensics put the evidences together
it's not god of the gaps just in the
same ways if you put food for a dog and
then you go away and that and the food
is eaten you're not going to say that's
a dog of the gapps argument it's just an
abductive inference which he does every
time and if it's not that if you don't
do an abductive inference then all of
the cases he's represented have been
miscarriages of justice which I'm sure
he wouldn't do and the point here is
this the point is when we put the
totality of evidence asking for more
evidence you know it's like when we've
given you ontological metaphysical a
priori a personal right scientific
physical mathematic probabilistic
evidences it's like asking for a torch
when you're in the middle of daylight
give me a torch but why do you need to
touch my friend everything around you
you're locked into the arguments
everywhere you go there's an arguments
there's evidence there science even to
the extent whereby even to the extent
whereby you're born with that feeling of
believing in
God and then you have to socially
construct the pudding - Justin Barrett
and others your atheism just like you
use other social constructed ideas like
secondary feminism liberalism I don't
think people don't know about liberalism
were women by the way you're talking
about what about these men they're all
men liberalism is written by men John
Locke who does Stuart Mill Rousseau want
to skew Thomas Hobbes I thought here I
don't see any women's names there so
frankly let's not play these games what
I will say is this what I will say is as
Muslims we have additional evidence and
this is the evidence from Revelation the
Quran says a woolly bear to roam free
edenal up woman body hardly him say ugly
bone that the Romans had been defeated
in lowland neighbor island and after
that defeat they would become victorious
it makes predictions which materialize
and look at this just as one piece of
evidence and you can look at my videos
for more but it's just one thing when
someone makes a succession of
predictions of the future what is the
probability that some of those
predictions will be false if you add all
of those things and you aggregate them
in your total probability chart and you
ask the question if someone makes all of
these if someone makes all of these
predictions of the future like the Quran
does what's the probability that this
could have been I guess well there's a
way of finding that out through
mathematical probability theory for
example or apostolic probability so
frankly we do have an argument it's not
and by the way there's something else
here very important he made a good point
he made a very good point
he said that why is it the case that
miracles are confined or time bound he's
right for a Christian that would be a
great argument if you say to a Christian
how comes Jesus rested dead when we
couldn't see it absolutely right about
that when the Quran says Omaha's a naked
black have fattened in a sea we have not
sent you to
except for Mohammed all of humankind the
reason why those were localized like
Jesus or Moses plain to see or whatever
may be is because they appealed or is
meant to appeal to that time and that
people as for the Quran itself it claims
to be the miracle it's an another Torah
miracle so that you can analyze it in
any time in any place so it's not giving
an unfair advantage to the primary
audience you can try and falsify the
Quran now it gives you a way to try and
do so you can try and imitate the Quran
now challenges it challenges you to do
so and you can try and look at those
things in the Quran which claim to be
happening in the future and analyze
whether they did in hindsight now
because we have seen whether I happen to
know for example these are some examples
now in the last 2 or 3 minutes I want to
say something important putting this
discussion to the side you know Edward
is one of our friends here in America
and the reason why I'm putting this in
the end is because I've kind of finished
everything and I wanted to say this he
wept actively to promote the rights of
Muslims in this country and its people
like Edward that allow for Muslims in
this country and in the West to be able
to be guaranteed the same kind of
freedoms frankly that other every other
person should have and I believe that if
you're going to believe in something be
consistent with it and though maybe not
in the field of atheism and God's
existence he might not be fully
consistent but in his morality he's a
man of consistency he opposes Trump's
ban on Muslims he's a friend of the
Muslims and what I want to end off by
saying here is this is the kind of
person who were happy to have as a
friend of the Muslim community here in
the USA
honestly after things like the
Christchurch massacre or other terrorist
attacks happening on both sites bad
things are happening we need to be able
to build bridges
I believe Edward is the man or the kind
of person Edward is is the kind of
person we need to be friends with we
need to invite to our houses we need to
be kind to we need to show courtesy to
and we to respect Jaime despite
religious or ideological disagreements
we will agree to disagree but we will
also agree to agree where our interests
are mutual and where we can oppose a
common threat to both of our existences
Edward is consistent because he does not
like arbitrariness which is a which is a
theme in liberalism where one community
are not treated the same as another
community it is a law and you believe in
liberalism let that law be applied to
everyone and he's done some great work
he has done some great work opposing
arbitrary kinds of judgments that have
happened in different states and he was
telling me about that and really and
truly we take our hats off to him and
his and people like
finally finally I want to say in my last
half a minute left that if I said
anything to offend anyone here that I
apologize that that was not my intention
and that obviously this is the subject
which we really feel passionate about
and as a superior to me
in knowledge and experience I want to
thank from the bottom of my heart
Edwards contribution to today's
discussion it's been edifying it's been
brilliant for me and I'm sure it's been
fantastic for you you're walking at any
time I'm sure I can say that on behalf
of this for the University and hopefully
we can meet another day thank you very
much
[Applause]
well thank you Mohammed the issue that
Mohammed raises again pinning his
argument on the concept of a necessary
being remember the problem with that is
the problem is that a necessary fact
cannot explain a contingent fact without
introducing a new contingent fact in
need of explanation and to see why
notice that a necessary fact cannot
explain a contingent fact by entailing
it because then any fact entailed by a
necessary fact must itself to be
necessary and this sets up the
regression all the way back into the
past which Muhammad is trying to avoid
now with respect to my comment that 99%
of all scientific discoveries will show
to be natural that doesn't mean the 1
percent will be supernatural it means
the opposite it means the likelihood of
anything being supernatural is very
implausible and the way I said it was
that unless something appears miraculous
like the Stars rearranging themselves
telling us what to do it is a God of the
gaps argument as far as the qur'an's
prediction is concerned both the Quran
and the Bible have failed to make the
kinds of pure predictions which would
show the supernatural now with respect
to the Quran it was finished in 632 but
it was not codified into a final written
form until 2018 years later in 650 by
the caliph Uthman and now the only
earliest version we have of a 90%
complete Quranic text is from the mere
eighth century which could be almost 80
years after the Quran was initially
given to Muhammad now another problem is
with respect to translations every time
I point out something to Muhammad about
the translations that I have before me
even eight or nine of them his responses
he disagrees with the translation I
don't necessarily disagree that Muhammad
might understand the Quran in the
original Arabic far better than all
these translations my argument is from
divine hiddenness if the Quran is God's
ultimate revelation to humanity it is
inconsistent with that purpose for us
who speak only English not to have a
reliable translation Muhammad was not
able to demonstrate how an immaterial
incorporeal being created time and space
see what Muhammad was trying to do as a
valiant attempt was to rescue was to
rescue some vestige of the supernatural
from a purely natural universe and
ultimately it was unsuccessful he was
not able to refute at all my argument
from evolution he did not refute my
argument from evil he was not able to
explain how an all-powerful God that can
prevent a lot of evil still has to allow
so much evil he did not adequately
refute my argument from divine
hiddenness because he was not able to
give a reason why a God who wants us to
know his will would withhold the very
evidence that we need to be able to
believe in that God I as an atheist gave
you clear examples of the type of
miraculous occurrences which would make
me turn into a believer in fact if my
dead father appear
right now transported Mohammed and me to
Mecca and told me and I knew it was my
dad that since dying he realized that
Islam was the perfect religion
I would convert right away so I'm
subject to an open to the evidence the
other thing that Muhammad did not refute
was my claim that the Quran liked the
Bible the Quran like the Bible demands
eternal punishment for choosing the
wrong religion I believe that we human
beings have a right to use our reason
and sense of justice
to say that it is wrong for any
all-powerful deity to condemn innocent
people to eternal suffering because of
an honest mistake in choosing the wrong
religion and so I believe to that extent
the Bible and the Quran are equally
equally false however I have to say the
Quran did improve on the Bible in one
area if you read Jeremiah 99 you see
that God threatens to make people eat
their sons and daughters in the Quran
there's no such vestige of cannibalism
so if God does exist I thank him for in
between the Bible and the Quran taking
human flesh off the menu
the Muhammad was unable to refute the
argument against a transcendental person
because if you are a person you have to
have some boundaries some limit to say
that you are not in time and space and
you are in time and space what are we
talking about is like some guy standing
up waist-deep in a hot tub he's half in
and half out how can you be partially in
time how can God enter time in order to
enter time you have to have a beginning
in time a timeless being cannot do
anything either can an immaterial being
now I know that the concept that death
is the end is very difficult for most
people to tolerate but on atheism what's
true is not what we would like to be
true what's true is what cold hard
reality shows is true there is no
example whatsoever of conscious
self-awareness being able to exist
without a fully functional physical
brain if it were so then Alzheimer's
disease would not be able to eclipse
consciousness again Alzheimer's disease
eclipses your consciousness but when you
die you're fully intact in an immaterial
form it can't happen that way also the
argument from evolution with the common
ancestry that we have with apes we
didn't evolve from apes but we spun
often had a common ancestor if you look
at the fossil record of the precursors
to homo sapiens who we are now
you see we evolved from a more primitive
life-form both the Bible and the Koran
accept the notion of Adam and Eve you
can't have an Adam and Eve if evolution
is true which it is because there was no
such thing as the first perfect human
couple we evolved like any other
creature so if there was no Adam and Eve
both the Bible and the Quran
are wrong in saying that there was and
of course if there was no Adam and Eve
then Christianity is completely wrong in
talking about the sin in the Garden of
Eden now another thing that Muhammad was
unable to do was to demonstrate and I've
seen other Muslim apologists try to do
this was to demonstrate that the
language or the mode of Arabic itself
used in the Quran had to have a divine
authorship you can have advanced
language or poetic or useful verse or
you can make innovations in language but
that does not show that there was a
supernatural origin also he failed to
show us what specific predictions in the
Quran took were made that turned out to
be true on one of his YouTube videos he
talks about a Roman war which the Quran
predicted the Romans would lose well I
looked it up that war ended in 628 seee
and the Quran was finished in 632 CE II
so the Quran did not predict anything in
the future
the other aspect of all of this is the
incompatible properties of the concept
of God the very concept of God God
cannot be both omnipotent and omniscient
if God is omnipotent
it means God can do anything including
change his mind but if God is omniscient
he always knew what he was going to do
in the very end so he cannot change his
mind
so therefore the properties of
omniscience and omnipotence are
incompatible with respect to the
fine-tuning argument that sort of
Mohammed flirted with and then moved
away from if we look at that on theism
you would not need any kind of
fine-tuning because God would
capable of making us live in any
environment so the whole notion of fine
tuning is nonsensical but yet if you
look at a theism and there is no
all-powerful God who could make us live
in any environment then we wouldn't then
we would need fine-tuning because there
is no supernatural being to sustain us
any which way which makes fine-tuning
curiously more likely on atheism now
I've heard Muslim apologists say that
the Quran predicted that the universe is
expanding I looked at four different
translations and the only one that used
the term expanding there was Mustapha
kitab in 2016 the three other
translations including the classic
Pickthall and abdullah yusuf ali all of
them had the vastness of space already
existing so if the Quran did predict
that the universe is expanding which
meant that the Quran had divine
foreknowledge before science that the
Big Bang occurred then only one out of
four translations shouldn't be able to
show that so once again on divine
hiddenness if the Quran is what God
wants me to believe then the Quran
should have been translated into ink
true also on the argument from evil and
I've touched upon this is the
distribution of pleasure and pain on
theism we would expect that horrendous
pain would only exist if there's a
purpose that would aid our survival or
our reproduction so if I put my hand on
the hot stove its hurt so I take my hand
away but let's say again I or some
innocent animal are caught in a forest
fire and were unable to pull away from
the pain and we suffer a horrible death
well the pain of that burning to death
did not contribute to my survival or
reproduction and so on atheism it's
understandable on theism it's it's not
understandable I referred earlier to the
Bayesian probability analysis on
Bayesian probability analysis which is
widely used you have to have prior
knowledge of something there's no prior
knowledge of the supernatural so if you
use Bayesian confirmation a predictive
ability you would not be able to predict
the supernatural if the supernatural
existed there would be evidence of it if
consciousness could exist without a
functional physical brain there'd be
evidence of it if the Bible or the Quran
predicted something which could only
have been known by miraculous means when
it was written there would be evidence
of it if we humans were specially
created there wouldn't be overwhelming
evidence that we evolved from ape-like
creatures from a common ancestor with
apes so with all of the evidence a
cumulative case shows the universe is
natural and not supernatural and that
God does not exist thank you
[Applause]
and with that something that we conclude
the debate does that go okay to everyone
for coming out with really appreciate
see you guys again in the future and
mail look and me everyone give them
another round of applause
[Applause]
to give a big thank you to another key
organizer his name is object man and he
did a lot of this work and I want to
give him a really big donations really
big and it's all love before everyone
leaves something is super important
again if anyone is able to we are really
really asking for donations help cover
costs for the trip I'm going on the
event so if anyone wants to marry the
box with their needs outside there's
also some animal would eat this MSA I'm
gonna be appreciate anything and
everything exactly all thanks for coming
everyone in trouble Habibi